Stephen will shed I did join Stephen is
an artist who creates incredibly
intricate drawings of cityscapes I love
killing toll buildings school
skyscrapers guidelines gate scenes and
he does this entirely from memory when
Stephen was three he was diagnosed as
autistic he was completely mute and
lived entirely in his own world
early on Stephens teachers noticed he
loved to draw he had found his way to
connect with others even has the ability
to look at a subject one and then draw
an accurate and detailed picture of it
including panoramas of entire cities
based off just a quick look I'll go up
from the helicopter and it was memorize
it and then up to in on a helicopter and
Jace back at our hotel and then start to
do for his incredible talent launched an
artistic career that has taken him
around the world
Los Angeles Dubai piston Texas and Tokyo
in Japan and that's just to name a few
New York my favorite Empire State
Building provides a building and a lots
of yellow New York taxi cabs and it even
has no plans of stopping anytime soon
someone told me though people like me
drawings feel good always be happy about
it
[Music]